richard dawkins coined the term meme in
his 1976 book The Selfish Gene and what
he proposed was that human culture was
composed at least in part of elements
units that were like genes in that they
were copied and copied and copied and
copied and copied and it was the
differential copying the differential
replication of these items these means
that accounted for the excellent design
of so much in human culture this is a
very repugnant and offensive idea to
many people especially in the humanities
they wanted to hang on to the idea of
the godlike genius creator who out of
sheer conscious brilliant comprehension
makes all these wonderful things whether
they're poems or or bridges or whatever
he was hanging in effect
well yes people do make amazing things
but if you look at the profit at the
project in detail you see that they
couldn't do that if they hadn't filled
their head with all these informational
things which are like genes which are
also information but they're not passed
down through the germline they're not
passed down through through the sperm
and the egg you don't get them with your
genes you get them from the ambient
culture from your parents from your
peers from the society in which your
race it requires perception a lot of
people think well wait a minute is a
huge dissing algae here genes our DNA
what's the DNA it means and the first
thing you have to appreciate is no genes
aren't DNA genes are the information
carried by the DNA genes are no more DNA
than palms are made of ink I mean you
can send somebody a pond that's written
in ink or you can say aloud there's many
different ways of transmitting that poem
or saving that poem
place to another the same thing is true
of jeans once you get used to thinking
of jeans as not DNA but the information
carried by the patterns of the
nucleotides in DNA then you can see that
there really is a nice parallel well
then what's playing the role of DNA in
the land of culture what are the
physical implementation well they're
wonderfully various there is ink on
paper there's lines carved into stones
there's lines drawn in the fan
there's skywriting and of course there's
what we're doing right now
there's audible language and one of the
great features of language not
sufficiently appreciated by those who
aren't linguists is that what makes
language a potent medium for the
transmission of information is that it's
digitized in the same way that DNA is
digitized it's composed of fundamental
elements in the case of DNA is ACGT four
different nucleotides in the case of
language it's 20 to 30 phonemes we are
designed to pick up the phonemes of our
native language and then automatically
to categorize incoming utterances by
correcting them to the norm of whatever
the phonemes in our language are and it
doesn't matter whether I say dog or dog
or dog argh God all comes out of the dog
doesn't take any effort to recognize
that these are all tokens of the same
type
that's digitization and that's what
makes it possible to transmit
information from one person to another
to another and the person in the middle
doesn't have to understand what it means
all I have to do is copy the sequence of
phonemes and the message will get
through it looks as if we're pretty
stupid we're just just walking breathing
vectors that are carrying all these
memes or
in our heads sort of like having a cold
you know like viruses and they are like
viruses and the first means we're even
more like viruses because they were they
weren't particularly useful
they were just habits that we're
catching in one way or another and they
spread or not and they didn't have to do
any good they just had to be not too
harmful and they kept it as long as
their vectors stayed alive and spread
them then they could they could spread
they could thrive just like the cold
virus cold virus isn't for anything
except for making more copies of the
cold virus and early memes were just
like that
but eventually competition for utility
arose and now memes whether they were
words or other ways of doing things that
actually were a benefit would spread
differentially because they were other
ways of doing things that could be not
even recognized it's just that those who
adopted them fared better than those who
didn't and before you know it you have
competitive differential replication of
cultural items and that's what does all
the heavy lifting and design work in
getting culture human culture off the
ground it's only very recently that
we've had people who style themselves as
meme creators as designers of memes and
think aboutt coined words you have a
vocabulary 50 60 70 thousand words very
few of them were deliberately coined by
anybody yet they're all useful and they
are all robust enough to survive until
they go extinct words go extinct all the
time so it is with culture much more
generally it's composed of elements
which have histories they have lineages
they can combine in ways that genes
normally don't but can and the result is
this tremendous creative stew of
differential replication creating
ideas that people latch onto and benefit
from without having to understand why
they're good or how they're good and
they never would have invented them
themselves that is a brilliant piece of
engineering and nobody invented
you
[Music]